Shut up. Yeah, that's one of the fastest
ways to become more influential
according to who I consider to be the
godfather of communication, Dale
Carnegie, who wrote the book How to Win
Friends and Influence People. And in
this video, I want to share with you the
three biggest lessons from this book
that will make you a more influential
communicator. My name is Vin, and for
more than a decade, I've taught millions
of people around the world how to become
a better communicator. And this year, I
also became an author. [cheering] So to
celebrate over the next few months, I'll
be sharing the most powerful lessons
from my favorite communication books
that have shaped me and the person that
I've become. And the funny thing is I
was given this book when I was about 12.
My uncle Carr gave it to me. And I
looked at the title and I thought to
myself, I don't need help making
friends. I know how to do that and
influence. I didn't even know what that
word meant nor why it mattered. So I
thanked my uncle and I didn't read it.
Sorry, Uncle K. It wasn't until I was in
my early 20s when the desire to make
something of my life started to set in.
Then this book hit me very differently
because it taught me a lesson that has
shaped my life ever since. Success
leaves clues. There are people who've
spent decades working things out and
then for 20 to $30 they put the
blueprint in your hands. I didn't have
to work everything out by myself. I
could stand on the shoulders of giants
and Dale Carnegie was one of the first
giants in my life. Lesson one, start
with what they want. If you want to
influence someone, stop beginning with
what you want and start with what they
want. Dale uses this wonderful analogy
about fishing. I mean, he loves
strawberries and cream. I mean, I do,
too. But when he goes fishing, does he
put strawberries and cream on the hook?
No. Because the fish doesn't care what
Dale Carnegie likes for dessert. The
fish wants worms. And this sounds so
obvious, but I realized that I recently
had made the exact same mistake with my
wife. I love camping. I love everything
to do with the camping. And when I first
tried to convince Paywen to go, I sold
it to her using the things that excite
me about camping. So, I'd say things
like, "Paywen, imagine this. We're out
in the wilderness with the children.
There are no bathrooms. We'll have to
dig some holes. It's cold, so we're
going to have to make our own fire, cut
down our own wood, and we have to
survive." And I would get more excited
with every sentence. Meanwhile, poor
Pwen on the other side is looking at me
like I'm describing a hostage situation.
I was selling her my version of
strawberries and cream. Actually, no. In
this scenario, I was more selling her
hypothermia. The problem was not camping
itself. I was explaining it from my
point of view. I needed to think about
what motivated my wife pay when. And
what would have motivated her? Quality
time with the family, disconnecting from
our devices, watching the kids explore
nature. It's the same damn camping trip,
but it would be a completely different
conversation and we probably would have
went camping. And this is where so many
of us get persuasion wrong, including me
still to this day. We spend all our time
explaining why we care. But if you're
trying to influence someone else, at
some point, you have to get out of your
own head and think about what's in it
for them. You got to look at it from
their perspective. What do they care
about? What do they want more of? What
do they want less of? I had to learn
this in my own business, too. For years,
I thought I was selling communication
skills. Use your voice. Improve your
body language. Become a better
storyteller. Those were my versions of
strawberries and cream. But most people
aren't lying there awake at 2:00 in the
morning at night thinking my melodic
variation is inadequate. They're
thinking, "Why don't people take me
seriously? Why do I freeze in meetings?
Why do I feel invisible?" [music] You
see, they're not buying communication
skills. They're trying to be more
confident, more respected, and they're
trying to become more influential. And
this is one of the key reasons why I
wrote Before We Forget How to Connect to
help you learn how to use your voice,
your body language, and storytelling so
you can be more influential. But then
also there's a whole section dedicated
[music] to listening so that you can
understand what's important to the other
person. And look, I don't want you to
just read the ideas in this book. I want
to help you practice them. So, we've
created a special pre-order bonus. If
you pre-order the book this month,
you'll get a free ticket to join me live
for my 3-day online event called Break
the Mold, where you work on your voice
so you can come across with more
authority. You work on your body
language so we can increase your
presence. and I'll teach you how to
express your ideas in a way that's
clear, concise, and coherent. So, the
link is below if you want to pre-order
the book, or you can scan the QR code on
screen. Lesson two, listen before you
solve. While we're on the subject of
getting out of our own heads, Dale's
second lesson is something I'm still
having to work at every single day, and
it's listening. My default mode is to
listen to solve. You tell me a problem,
I'm in. Okay, here's what you need to
do. Step one is this. Step two is this.
I've made you a spreadsheet with a
12-week action plan. You didn't ask for
the action plan, but I've made you one
anyway. That's my go-to move. My other
bad habit is that I'm too quick to find
my version of your story. So, if you
tell me you're tired and exhausted, then
I'm very quickly going to say, "Oh, you
think you're tired? Do you have two
kids, two dogs, two cats, four chickens,
and three alpacas? Do you?" I always
think it's a game of comparison. So,
there are two ways I accidentally make
the conversation about me. one, I solve
your story, or two, I match and then one
up your story. It's super annoying. And
I'm not saying this is always bad.
Sometimes people actually want advice.
They want a 12step action plan.
Sometimes people want you to share
experiences with them because that's
what creates connection. The problem is
timing. If you do these things too
quickly as people are talking, I've
already made the conversation about me
before you finish telling your story.
And as a teacher, I used to do this all
the time in my workshops. A student
would come up to me and say, "Hey, Vinn,
I need to sell more confident in
meetings." And immediately my
communication teacher brain wants to fix
it. I'd say, "Vol, rate of speech, body
language, it's easy. Let's go. Let's
make the change." But if I stuck with
them just a little longer, ask them a
few more questions. Hey, tell me more.
When did you notice your confidence
start to drop? Sometimes the real
problem they're experiencing is
completely different to the one they
were showing. Maybe a senior team member
constantly interrupts them. Maybe they
know their subject really well, but the
moment they get challenged, their mind
goes blank. Maybe they're not struggling
to speak. Maybe they're just terrified
of being wrong. If I solved the first
sentence they gave me, I might have
solved the wrong damn thing. People know
more about their own inner world than
you do. But because we're so eager to
contribute and help, sometimes we
interrupt the discovery process. So,
here's something I've been trying to
practice. Before you give the advice,
before you share your version of the
story, ask three more follow-up
questions to the person who's talking.
Tell me more about what happened. How
did that make you feel? Is there
anything else? I want you to just stay
in their world for three questions
longer. Because what does this do? This
will show them that you care. And once
they know you care, then when you share
your version of the story, then when you
share your thoughts, maybe even your
advice, they're much more likely to
listen to you because now the bridge of
connection has been built. And that
brings me to the third lesson in this
wonderful book, names. And this one is
strangely personal to me because my name
is Vin Jang. V I N H G I A N G. And
throughout my life, people have
forgotten it. They've misspelled it. I
don't know how on earth they
mispronounced Vin. There was an event I
did years ago where the organizer
spelled my name incorrectly. Yeah. And I
got really upset. Far more upset than
the situation deserved. The poor damn
event organizer did not deserve it. It
was a mistake. But they accidentally
received years of accumulated
frustration from me in that moment.
Because when I look back at that
situation now, I wasn't angry because of
one spelling mistake. For a long time in
my life, I felt forgettable. And seeing
my name spelled wrong just touched a
nerve that night. And that's what Dale
Carnegie understood because your name
may be a small collection of sounds, a
small sequence of letters, but to you,
it's you. It's yours. Years ago, I used
to run a workshop experiment in my
classes and I'd have 40 to 50 students.
And before the workshop, I would
memorize by looking at their photos
every single person's name. And as they
walk into the workshop wearing no badge,
I'd immediately say, "Hey, Sarah.
Morning, David. Hey, Quinn." And you
should have seen the look on their
faces. What fascinated me was how
disproportionately meaningful such a
small thing felt. I hadn't given them
money. I hadn't bought them a present. I
just remembered a word, their word. But
most of us don't forget names because we
can't remember them. We simply are not
paying attention when the name is given
to us. You know the moment when I say,
"Hi, my name's Vinn." And they say, "Hi,
my name's Michael." and you're thinking
about, okay, so once this person stops
talking, I immediately have to introduce
myself. How can I introduce myself in
ways that's exciting? Wait, am I
smiling? Wait, am I doing something
weird with my hands? And then 30 seconds
later, the name Michael has disappeared
from your memory. And then now you spend
the rest of the conversation going, "Oh,
mate, buddy, old pal, chief. Oh, champ."
Trust me, when you do that, they know
that you've forgotten their name. How do
I know? Because I've been called out on
it. And this connects all three of
Dale's lessons beautifully. First of
all, what do they want? Second of all,
what are they trying to tell you? And
then thirdly, what is their name? Do you
notice the direction of your attention
where it actually should be going? When
I was much younger, I thought being good
with people meant that I needed to be
more interesting. So, I tried to be more
impressive. I told my stories. I tried
to make people laugh by being
interesting and being funny. And to be
clear, those things did help. But I
thought that I had to do that 100% of
the time. I thought influence was the
ability to hold somebody's attention and
only that just that. But so much of Dale
Carnegiey's work points us in the
opposite direction. Influence isn't just
about your ability to hold somebody's
attention. It's also your ability to
give somebody else your attention. Uh,
when my uncle gave me this book at 12
years old, I thought I didn't need help
making friends. [music] And nearly three
decades later, I can admit truthfully
that I probably should have read it
sooner because it did help me build
better relationships. It did help me
become more influential. And yes, it
pretty damn well did help me make more
friends in life. Dale Carnegie is no
longer here for me to thank personally,
but his ideas are still helping people
almost a century later. So Dale, cheers,
mate. Make sure you go and read How to
Win Friends and Influence People if you
haven't already. And remember, if you do
want to go deeper into my work with my
book before we Forget How to Connect.
It's available for pre-order. The link
is down below in the description, or you
can scan the QR code on screen right
now. And remember the pre-order bonus.
You'll get to join me live at our event
called Break the Mold. That's book
number two done. And if you missed last
week's book, the one I reviewed last
week, which is Cu's by Vanessa Van
Edwards, also an amazing book. If you
missed it, make sure you click this
video up